multiplique estos dos números y expresa
el resultado en notación científica ok
notación científica bueno me parece que
lo más apropiado sería recordar qué
significa esto de la notación científica
y es simplemente tomas un número y lo
expresas como una multiplicación de
algún otro número y multiplicando a
alguna potencia de 10 okey donde este
número
es mayor o igual que uno aquí está este
número a pero tiene que ser
estrictamente menor que 10 ya que estos
dos números ya están escritos en
notación científica si se fijan este 9.1
es mayor o igual que 1 y menor que 10 al
igual que 3.2 entonces pues voy a
empezar por reescribir esto tenemos por
aquí 9.1 por voy a usar esta anotación
por el momento
10 elevado a las 6 y luego por 3.2 por
10 a lo menos 5 10 al menos 5 ahora aquí
estos 4 números se están multiplicando y
la multiplicación es asociativa y
conmutativa ok eso de conmutativa
significa que los podemos cambiar de
orden y eso es justo lo que vamos a
hacer entonces vamos a empezar por
cambiarlos de lugar vamos a poner por
aquí 9.1 x
punto 2 y luego por 10 a las 6 10 a las
6 y finalmente por 10 a la menos 5 por
10 a la menos 5 que ya están todos los
multiplican 2 y entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es multiplicar primero estos dos
números y después estos dos números y lo
que nos quede vamos a multiplicar lo
entonces para hacer esta multiplicación
vamos a escribirlo por aquí 9.1 por 3.2
estamos multiplicando y lo que yo hago
es pensar que tengo aquí un 91 y un 32 y
hacer una multiplicación normal y ya
después vemos cómo cambia esto del punto
decimal aunque ahí tenemos 2 por 12 2
por 9 18 y ahora vamos con el 3 entonces
tenemos que poner por aquí un 0 porque
pues aquí en realidad no vamos a
multiplicar 31 por 3 en realidad vamos a
multiplicar 3
por 91 porque este 3 está en el lugar de
las decenas entonces lo que nos quede de
3 por 91 lo tenemos que multiplicar por
10 además y de ahí sale este 0 aunque
entonces 3 por 1 3 y 3 por 9 20 7
entonces sumemos aquí 20 es un 28 3 es
once ponemos porque une y llevamos 11 12
+ 7 9 y finalmente 2 bueno entonces 91
por 32 es 2 1912 pero lo que realmente
nos interesa es cuánto vale 9.1 por 3.2
y entonces lo único que nos falta es
contar cuántos decimales hay o sea
cuántos dígitos a la derecha de un punto
decimal hay que en este caso sólo hay
dos este es uno y este es otro y la
misma cantidad de números decimales es
la que tenemos que poner en el resultado
entonces por aquí va el punto decimal
para que tenga dos números decimales
así es que 9.1 por 3.2 esta
multiplicación de aquí
29.12 pero esto está multiplicando algo
que nos quede de multiplicar estos dos
números ahora esta multiplicación es
súper sencilla porque tenemos
exactamente la misma base que tenemos 10
a la 6 por 10 a la menos 5 y cuando
multiplicamos cosas que tienen la misma
base lo que tenemos que hacer es dejar
la base tal cual como está y sumar los
exponentes entonces aquí nos queda 6 más
menos 5 eso es 1 entonces nos quedan 10
a la 1 que a fin de cuentas es igual a
10 pero no importa ahora nosotros
podemos pensar que con esto ya
terminemos que ya expresamos a nuestro
número connotación científica pero no
resulta que este número no está
cumpliendo con las condiciones
necesarias recuerden que tienen que ser
mayor o igual que 1 eso está muy bien
pero también tiene que ser estrictamente
menor que 10 entonces tenemos que
cambiar este número
por algún otro número que sí cumpla con
estas propiedades que en realidad lo
único que tenemos que hacer es mover
este punto decimal un lugar a la
izquierda aquí el número que tenemos que
escribir es 2.912 ahora cómo le hacemos
para pasar de este número a este número
pues bueno nosotros sabemos que si
tomamos este número y lo multiplicamos
por 10 entonces obtenemos este número ok
entonces este número es equivalente a la
multiplicación de estos dos números pero
además nos falta multiplicar por 10 a la
1 y listo este número si es equivalente
a este número que es la multiplicación
de estos dos números y bueno si
escribimos de una forma más compacta
este número tenemos 2.912
por y aquí podemos multiplicar 10 por 10
esto es cómo multiplicar 10 a la 1 por
10 a la 1 que ya sabemos que es igual a
10 elevado a la 112 y listo
este número de aquí es igual a la
multiplicación de estos dos números y
además si está escrito en notación
científica aunque hay porque esto si es
mayor o igual que 1 y menor estricto que
10 y lo estamos multiplicando por una
potencia de 10